once again All-Star Pascal asiacom
[Music]
time is going
to King Grandma we've got a beautiful
queen Tams and to start us off give it
up for my boy burn a boy
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen they call me burner
boy and I'm about to take you on the
journey through Africa without even
going on a plane
introducing you to me and a couple of my
people
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
special
[Music]
everybody
and it's over
[Music]
[Applause]
Everybody Clap Your Ass Like This
[Music]
baby
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
baby gonna give me
[Applause]
finally
[Music]
oh yeah
sometimes
[Music]
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
yeah
because I wanted my information
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't even know the kind of things
why are you trying to tell me all these
things
[Music]
now if you need somebody
the noise in my mind
we'll try to get by
[Music]
trouble
I really need
again
[Music]
sometimes
morning but I need sugar
[Music]
I know what you
find me
time take time
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah
everybody
[Music]
tell me why you're crying I'm getting
big deal
[Music]
is
if you want is
[Music]
[Applause]
please
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
defense
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
manipulate
Salt Lake City one more time Make some
noise for an incredible Halftime Show
featuring burner boy Rema Tims Adam
Blackstone and the all-star band